okay so I mentioned this briefly
yesterday I want to spend a little bit
more time on it and what I'm gonna share
with you here I want you to understand
is not unique it's not an aberration and
that's really the reason why I I'm
sharing it because I want you to know
that this is what it's like when you
engage on these issues over the last 24
hours or so pro-abortion people have
been sending me messages threatening to
kill me rape my wife rape my children my
five-year-old daughter
they've wished death on me and my
children they've wished rape on my
daughter on my wife on myself and I'm
talking here about just the explicitly
violent messages now if we wanted to get
into the standard kind of vile vicious
insults and that sort of thing well I've
got hundreds of those of course but
putting those to the side par for the
course as those are unfortunately they
shouldn't be but they are what I want to
focus on are as I said the violent
messages either threats of or wishes of
violence against me or my family because
of my pro-life you specifically what has
provoked it seems some of these
responses is that I have expressed my
view that abortion should be illegal in
every case including rape and I have
explained why I feel the way I'm not
going to get into the whole explanation
now I've been doing that all week you
can read what I've written about it I
have explained in detail why I believe
that that abortion should be illegal in
every case including rape and just to
summarize in one sentence it comes down
to the fact that in my view the unborn
child is a person and as such as
deserving of all the same rights as any
other person of all the same basic human
rights and as such it's not okay to kill
them for any reason it is another way of
putting it as it is in my view never
acceptable to kill an innocent and
defenseless person intentionally never
acceptable and the manner of their
conception is not an exception to that
rule
it can't be okay so that's that's my
view
in order to show their deep abiding
concern for rape victims these people
however have been expressing their wish
that I become one myself a rape victim
or that my children become rape victims
so you can go to my Twitter right now
and the pinned tweet has a thread with a
bunch of the screenshots of these
threats I'm gonna go ahead and read the
worst ones to you like I've said I've
gotten hundreds of messages I couldn't
possibly read them all I don't possibly
have the energy to read them all so I
can't even tell you if these are
actually the worst ones these are just
the worst of the ones I've seen and so
we're gonna like I said read some and
I'm gonna read some of these partially
not gonna read some of these go into
great detail I won't read all the
details I don't think we necessarily
need context for this sort of stuff so
one person says I'll rape your daughter
and your wife then you tell me what you
want to do you piece of s so on and so
forth Jake Fahey messages and says wish
I could punch your dumbass face you
effing Mook
I wish rape upon every female in your
family so they are forced to have the
child someone else says come to reading
and I'll spin your jaw you sex offender
someone else says you are the best
reason for abortion I've ever
encountered it's a crime that your
mother failed to exercise her right and
you now breathe the free air one can
only hope that by some happening that
air and judgment is remedied this is not
a threat but a hope a wish that you and
all you who think as you do are
permanently silenced Andrew stern at the
real Dru ski says you're an effing piece
of s I hope I meet you one day and get
to show your face how I feel Allie at
Ali's 16 William says hope your daughter
gets raped at hey guppy ey ghost says
absolute effing idiots don't reproduce
abort all three of your already born
children Joey Nichols says well you are
the exact reason there should be
abortion clearly your parents were not
ready to have you
raise you to be an ignorant clown feel
free feel bad for your kids they are
going to turn out like scum just like
their dad at CB v r NS says you are an
effing [ __ ] wish your mom aborted you
I hope your daughters have millions of
abortions someone else emails email this
to me anonymously I hope your wife and
daughter are both brutally raped someone
else says you should jump off a bridge
and save the world a little bit of
oxygen you don't deserve to walk the
planet you piece of s someone else says
kill yourself there's a lot of kill
yourself messages won't even read all
them someone else says kill yourself
dude really your family will be better
off without you someone else at Fox drop
and this is at Fox drop a.m. Oh F F
underscore says your mother should have
aborted you so L says I'll have you
clapped mate
I think that's British for have you shot
another message come to reading you're
getting slashed than other violent
threats from there at Lola the bong from
San Francisco couldn't be any more
stereotypical there says you're an
effing idiot I hope you get raped and so
as I said those are just some of the
lowlights from what I read now first of
all some of these people sent me these
messages with their real names and
pictures attached the guy who threatened
to rape my wife and children
his name is Tyler nowicki or no Vicky I
don't know how to pronounce it and an
OWI cki I have his picture up on my page
you can go I would really recommend that
you go look at his picture because this
man is is is shouldn't be allowed around
a lot this is this is obviously a
dangerous sick person who shouldn't be
allowed around children and the reason
why and you know fortunately I published
his name and his picture and I got
thousands of retweets
I want his friends and family and his
employer if he has one to know that this
is the kind of person that he is the guy
who riched wish rape on every female
member of my family is named Jeff Fahey
as I mentioned his picture and Twitter
handle is up on my page as well now the
thing is these guys they I don't think
they realize this they realize it now
they're starting to realize it but these
guys have really screwed up their lives
it's just not smart
I mean it's evil first of all and
disgusting but also very profoundly
stupid to send this kind of crap to a
guy with two hundred thousand Twitter
followers seven hundred thousand plus
Facebook followers not to mention a
podcast and a daily column on one of the
most widely read conservative sites in
the world because I will be writing
about this later today and once again
linking to their pictures and faces and
and an information so now your name and
your face and the atrocious disgusting
thing that you said will be plastered
everywhere forever and and any future
employer will find it when they google
you that's that's the problem Taylor
nawicki and Jeff Fahey is that for ever
now whenever someone Google's you
they're going to find that you
threatened to rape a child or wish to
rape on a child uh this is really a life
altering decision that you guys have
made and you deserve that consequence
you absolutely deserve it as I said
yesterday when when you say stuff like
that it's not gonna remain private I
will I'm not gonna respect your privacy
and say oh well they wanted that to
remain between us no you see I think
I've got I says that when you have a
platform maybe you don't understand this
because you don't but I do so I'm gonna
share this with everyone and now they're
all going to know that this is the kind
of thing that you say to people and
people need to know I mean I I wouldn't
I wouldn't want you around all right
well I certainly wouldn't want you
around my own children considering what
you said but I wouldn't if I was some
other person I wouldn't want you around
my children either given that this is
the way you speak and so now everyone's
going to know that threatening or
wishing rape on a child look there's
there are some lines you just don't
cross and and I have I I think I have a
lot of tolerance for you know as I said
I get vile disgusting messages all the
time and I just ignore them I don't
respond I don't publish it I don't try
to embarrass anyone but when you
threaten or wish rape on my children you
have gone way way way over the line look
that's not the line okay the line is way
back over there that's way over the line
and so when you do that you cause
serious problems for yourself and those
problems are not gonna go away anytime
soon
you don't say this stuff about my family
I'm not gonna tolerate it I'm gonna
protect them and not just protect them
physically but I'm gonna protect their
honor which includes punishing you for
what you've said about them and that's
the way this goes boys it's just that's
the way it goes you're gonna learn a
valuable lesson and you're gonna learn
it the hard way
now you may remember when Johan Omar was
getting death threats and she said she
said she was getting death threats and
you know I believe that she was we were
told by the media that criticism of Omar
was putting her life at risk putting her
life in jeopardy
we shouldn't criticize her because it
you know it's it puts her at risk and it
encourages this kind of thing well I
wonder will the left show a similar
concern for the lives of my children and
my wife and myself of course
unlike Omar I would never actually
suggest that criticism of me puts my
life at risk okay I don't think that you
can criticize me all you want in fact
you could say whatever you want about me
when when you get into threats that's
different but you could say whatever you
want about me the problem is when as I
said you get into threats or you bring
my family into it that's when you've
that's when you're gonna that's when
there's gonna be problems but whatever
you want about me you can say but if
we're talking
irresponsible rhetoric which may
encourage deranged and sick and
disgusting people to say these kinds of
things well what about all the leftists
who have been lying and accusing me of
defending rape or being pro rape simply
because I don't think babies conceived
in rape should be should be executed I
mean Tom Arnold
just as one example Tom Arnold sent a
tweet implying that I actually am a
rapist
so Tom Arnold Tom's got Tom Arnold for
whatever reason has a lot of followers
and for what for reasons that escaped me
people listen to what this guy has to
say he sent a tweet implying that I'm a
rapist and then he defended that tweet
by claiming that I that I write that he
as he says I write a lot of pro rape
content now that's a lie of course but
is that not irresponsible rhetoric is
that not inflammatory I mean if someone
can be blamed for the death threats sent
to Ilhan Omar because they criticized
her can I blame Tom Arnold for the
threats that are coming to my family for
calling me a rapist I just I can't take
the hypocrisy and I especially can't
take the way the pro-abortion side
dresses itself up as loving and tolerant
and accepting and so and so on so
concerned for women and children I know
that it's not the case I know it first
of all because they advocate the murder
of children so that's what pretty debts
oh that's a giveaway right there but
second of all I know it because of my
own experience with them I had a lot of
experience with these people I see the
kinds of things they say when they think
no one is watching and even sometimes
when they know people are watching I've
seen it for myself and this is not just
my experience like I said talk to any
pro-lifer in the movement talk to women
especially think about what think about
what some of these some of these some
scumbag men might have said to me if I
was a woman I mean think about the
things they're saying to me as a man but
imagine if I was a woman and they were
directing this kind of scorn at me
that's the dirty little secret that it's
only an it's only a secret because the
media keeps it a secret but the
pro-abortion side will not respect
any boundary it will not adhere to any
ethical code at all if you attack their
cherished institution of baby murder
if you desecrate the altar upon which
they worship the altar that happens to
be soaked in the blood of 60 million
dead children this is what they do and I
wanted you to see that which is why I
share this with you today by the way I
could also if I had the time and energy
compile a separate list of the tweets
from from other leftist essentially
agreeing with the threats and and
telling me that I deserve them because
of my pro-life position there are many
many many in that vein and if you go you
can read them for yourself and go on
Twitter I just I'm not going to put them
all together I don't have time for that
but there are people saying literally
you deserve this you deserve for people
to wish rape on your children because
you disagree with abortion it's you know
one other thing about this some people
have said hey it's just the Internet you
know don't make a big deal about it is
just how people act on the Internet
happens to me all the time
first of all unless you have a large
platform and you engage on controversial
issues like abortion now if you do and
you say this happens to you sometimes or
frequently I believe you but if you
don't I don't believe you it definitely
does not happen to you all the time
yeah it's of people with 14 followers
and that happens to me all the time no
it doesn't it has probably never
happened to you I use the internet for a
long time before I had a platform and
the worst they ever got were some salty
Facebook comments usually from people I
knew you know just just telling me they
disagree in vulgar ways or whatever but
strangers across the country wishing
death and rape on me and my family no I
never experienced that I you know
I don't think that some of the people
saying they've experienced it really
have and then the people say oh it
happens to me all the time yeah no it
probably doesn't unless again you have a
large platform and you regularly engage
on these kinds of issues but secondly if
this is normal it shouldn't be and the
fact that it's the Internet is
irrelevant since when did it become
acceptable and not a big deal to wish
rape on children just because you
disagree with someone's opinion yeah
it's on it's on the internet it's just
on the Internet well it's not the
Internet isn't saying this okay this is
not some kind of algorithmic code that's
coming up with this these are people
these are actual living people now they
may be people who act more like lizards
or snakes but they are people actual
live human beings so no it's not the
Internet it's people these are people
using the inner the Internet is just a
communication tool so there is no moral
difference between saying something
through the internet and saying it to
someone's face in fact saying it to
someone's face is is you may say you
arguably is is is not as bad as saying
it on the Internet
I would argue that whatever horrible
thing you have said on the Internet
and we've all said things on the
Internet we regret although hopefully
not anything quite as bad as what I just
read to you but we've all lost our
temper and and and said things that we
regret type things I mean the Internet
does tend to encourage that kind of
communication but whatever horrible
you have said on the internet is worse
on the internet than it would have been
had you said it in person not better
worse because because when when you say
it on the internet it has this extra
element of cowardice to it because at
least if you say to someone's face
you're not as much of a coward if you
only say horrible things on the internet
that means that you're not only a
horrible person but you're also a weak
pathetic coward if you say horrible
things to people's face well then you're
a horrible person yes but at least
you're less of a wimp about it
I mean if you're gonna walk up to
someone's face and say something like
that to them and give them the chance to
respond in whatever manner they deem
appropriate well then at least you're
not hiding behind a keyboard I think
people make these excuses that's just
the Internet I think the people that say
that it's because they know that they
themselves when protected by the cloak
of anonymity that the Internet provides
them will often spew the most vile and
vicious and disgusting rhetoric
imaginable and they know that about
themselves they know the kinds of
comments they leave under YouTube videos
and that sort of thing and this sort of
stuff they say on their anonymous
twitter accounts whether they don't even
have a picture of themselves or their
real name but they're tough guys with
their opinions on their anonymous
twitter accounts they know the kind of
stuff they say and they don't want to
think that their behavior online is a
reflection of their character well it is
whatever you say with your anonymous
twitter account that's you that's you
being a bad person that is you being a
sick disgusting bad cowardly scumbag
that's what that is that's who you are
if you're a bad person all the time
online you're just about you're a bad
person that's who you are that's your
character and on top of it as I said
you're a coward as well if you can if
you if you're comfortable with that if
you could say yes I'm a bad person in a
coward if you can embrace that about
yourself well then
go ahead but I don't think most people
can I mean it's just it's hard to go
through your life on a day-to-day basis
look in the mirror get up and you know
move about your day knowing that about
yourself so you want to pretend that
you're not but you are all right
speaking of stooping to the lowest lows
and having no ethical constraints at all
tucker carlson has been accused of it
accused of saying that it's honorable
and necessary to force rape victims to
have babies that's what he's accused of
saying it's honorable and necessary to
force rape victims that Biggs here's a
tweet from a Media Matters goon and as
you can see that the caption says Tucker
Carlson says it's honorable and
necessary to force women to give birth
after being impregnated by their rapists
and because of this tweet and others
like it people making this accusation
Carlson is beginning a lot of backlash
for this but let's click the video
provided in that tweet and see what it
actually says so look at this so this is
the modern Democratic orthodoxy if you
love women you'll encourage them to kill
their own offspring if you acknowledge
that children are sacred that being a
parent is honourable and necessary and
maybe even more meaningful than a trip
to Ibiza this summer then you sir are an
oppressor oh okay so he says that
Parenthood is honorable and necessary he
doesn't say that forcing rape victims
have babies is honorable necessary he's
speaking generally and saying Parenthood
is honorable innocent is anyone gonna
disagree with that well no see the thing
is they know they can't disagree with
that so instead they make up something
else that he said that he didn't really
say they just and they make up another
comment for him to have made so that
they can disagree with that because they
know what he actually said is totally
true Parenthood is an honorable and
necessary thing it's just again how do
you how do you
get up and look in the mirror knowing
that you're such a dishonest personally
I just don't get how people can
blatantly lie and then still live with
themselves and that's what you find on
the pro-abortion side unfortunately is
this just blatant dishonesty and it
comes from and ends justify the means
mentality it's when you're a moral
relativist and you believe there is no
objective right objective wrong
objective good or evil then you say well
whatever whatever a result I want to
bring about I can do anything to bring
about that result in and if my strategy
is successful in bringing about the
result that I want then it was a good
strategy and that's why it's so
important for us as conservatives to
repudiate the ends justify the means
meant out it's one of the reasons why I
am always so disturbed when I see that
kind of philosophy cropping up on the
right as it does sometimes because that
is exactly the way of thinking the
worldview the philosophy that we are
rejecting and fighting against and
defending against okay let's do
something a little bit more a little bit
more light hard a little bit more
encouraging I guess but a lot of dark we
have a dark time on on the show as it so
often is unfortunately well this is it's
go to the Daily wire now you know one of
the if you could even call it an
argument but one of the things that you
hear from pro-abortion people all the
time is and I've addressed it on plenty
of occasions in the past is this whole
thing about well you're only Pro birth
you don't care about you don't care
about women you don't care about babies
after they're born and all you care
about is babies in the womb which
obviously is such an unbelievably
ludicrous thing to say I mean the only
why do you think we care about babies in
the womb we care about papers no because
we care about people we think that they
are people which they are and because
they are people we care about them so
what should that tell you it tells you
we care about people
our whole argument is that this is a
person therefore
should care for them what does that mean
it means we care for people so to say
that yes
now as pro-lifers we are especially
focused on the unborn not exclusively
focused on them but especially focused
on them but that's because the unborn
happened to be especially victimized and
especially vulnerable and I would even
say from a legal standpoint exclusively
victimized they are the only group of
people left in America who are not
treated as people who are not given
personhood rights so that's why we focus
on them there are people out there who
take a special interest in caring for
the elderly which is great there are
people who take a special interest in
caring for the sick and the infirm for
the disabled would you ever say to
someone working at a nursing home that
oh you only care about old people yeah
you don't care about young people at all
you only care about it once they wait
once they reach 75 you don't care about
them after that there would be such a
it's such a stupid thing to say just
because I am focused on loving the this
group of people who I think are
vulnerable and in need of this kind of
attention doesn't mean I don't care
about other people someone who cares
especially about the elderly what does
that tell you about that person it tells
you that is someone who cares about
people it just it wouldn't make any
sense for I don't even know how a person
could develop that in their mind is to
develop an exclusive concern only for
this one group of people at a certain
age of development and and not for
anyone else it's just how you couldn't
even do that except maybe for pro boards
who only care about born people and done
and have ruled out unborn people
altogether so I guess they've pulled it
out off although for many of them I
don't know how much they really care
about born people either now okay so
that this is the point if you could say
that was made by someone on Twitter
Sarah Tuttle's singer she's a Israel of
times blogger she said a couple days ago
dear pro-life friends what have you
personally done to support lower lower
income single mothers I'll wait and she
obviously no this was supposed to be
flippant and sarcastic she she expected
that nobody would give any examples you
see when this comes up and
and a pro-abortion person says well you
don't do anything for born people well
pro-lifers do things for people all the
pro-lifers are very charitable they're
always helping women and children and
they're very charitable generous people
but they also don't feel comfortable
bragging about their charitable
endeavors we also know that we're told
not to do that in the gospel and many of
us are Christian so we don't want to do
it for that reason and I think that's
one of the reasons why pro abortions
people get it get away with this claim
is that they say oh you don't do
anything and then pro lifers are not
gonna line up and say oh yeah this is
what I do but I think sometimes we do
need to step up and say look that's not
true here's what I do for other people
and it's because we're not bragging
about ourselves we're not trying to put
ourselves on a pedestal what we're doing
is we're trying to defend this movement
that's a very important movement and so
it might be in that context important to
talk about the charitable things that we
do and so a lot of people stepped up and
they answer this person's question and
so just some examples of daily why our
compiles here of people talking about
the things they do for for the born so
some exams says I've spent the last 15
years serving breakfast once a month at
a homeless shelter and making lunches
for the same shelter once a month on a
separate weekend someone else's I'm the
president of the board of directors for
our local domestic violence shelter
someone else has donated to crisis
pregnancy centers volunteer for the
sisters of life offered to meet with
anyone in a crisis pregnancy to talk
about arranging to adopt their baby
applying for an open adoption take care
of a child whose mother doesn't think
she can right raise the baby and to keep
mother and child in each other's lives
someone else says we adopted our two
boys after we already had two girls
someone else's their foster parents
someone else says adopted one and took
him three Foster's who are now staying
permanently in addition to my six
natural children there's a lot of that I
mean pro-life people adopt all the times
that's the other stupid thing well I
don't see you out adopting kids what are
you talking about pro-lifers at this go
to a pro-life event and you're gonna
find so many adoptive families so many
adopted children they adopt kids all the
time of course they do they love
children that's the point that we're
making I remember one of the most
inspiring though ultimately sad things
that for my you know experience doing
doing all this remember a few years ago
there was a woman who wrote an article
maybe as a reddit post or something I
don't remember but talking about how she
was going to get an abortion and she was
she wrote this sort of goodbye letter to
her unborn child who she was about to
kill and so I wrote something responding
to that woman and just pleading with her
not to kill her child and doing my best
to convince her not to I I don't we
never I never heard from her I don't
know what ended up happening with that I
don't know if she got the abortion or
not it seems like it's good chance she
did but the inspiring thing was that I
remember when I posted that my response
there were so many on Facebook they're
all of these people my readers I mean
hundreds of them who were coming out of
the woodwork to say I will adopt this
woman's child volunteering to adopt the
child and being completely serious about
it a lot of them and said you know I've
already been through the process to get
a qualified rate for adoption you know
these are people that sounded
knowledgeable they were people talking
about the way that they're already
prepared you know how they already have
their house set up and they've got a
room ready and so these were these were
not just people saying it to make
themselves look good no there were all
of these people saying I will adopt this
woman's job I'll adopt him right now
this moment I'm ready again I don't I
don't know if that woman took anyone up
on that I don't think she did but yeah
any woman who doesn't who is you know in
a crisis pregnancy and doesn't feel like
they can care for the child there are
going to be pro lifers lined up around
the block to adopt that baby no there is
there is no unwanted baby in America
doesn't exist there is no such thing as
an unwanted baby there are so many
families who would love to adopt that
child and would
that job the only thing that needs to
happen is that the child needs to not be
killed first
so I mean pro-lifers I and I I mean in
you know if I know if for me and my
family we give to pregnancy centers we
give to sidewalk advocates we give to we
give to charities for the poor we try to
give as much as we can to just the
homeless and the impoverished in our own
community member just around Christmas
there was a woman who was about to be
kicked out of her apartment with her
kids and so we gave her money so she
could stay in the apartment and you know
is this is the kind of thing that pro
lifers do all the time because it's not
only because we love people but also
because we feel morally obligated to
help the less fortunate all right so
let's go to emails Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com Matt well show at gmail.com
this is from Paul says I believe we
already have an issue of women falsely
claiming rape I don't think that's
debatable if we gave the concession to
rape as an exception the concession if
we gave it a concession as awkwardly
word if there were rape exceptions for
abortion do you not think that would
exacerbate the problem of false rape
claims if all a woman has to do is claim
rape and she can get rid of her quote
problem then I believe we would
certainly see that abused yeah Paul
that is an issue it's by far not the
main reason to be opposed to rape
exceptions it's not even the second or
third or fourth or fifth reason because
all of those reasons are the same reason
and that is as I've been talking about
that an unborn child is a human being is
a person and all people have inherent
human rights and it is not okay to kill
an innocent and defenseless person at
all ever that's our reason that's why
we're except against exceptions because
an unborn child who is conceived in rape
even though the conception
through this hideously unspeakably evil
act that child is still a person and
still has rights that's our argument
right now as a secondary issue as a you
know there's another consideration of
less importance yeah there is it's
really kind of a logistical problem with
these exceptions where it's like when
you hear about well we'll have an
exception for health of the mother okay
well what does that mean and what you're
gonna find is so often is that health of
the mother it means mental health
physical health psychological health
spiritual health financial health I mean
anything could qualify as health and so
then anything is an exception and then
really you haven't done anything to
restrict abortion at all and so it's
sort of the issue with something like
rape because then you know how do you
legally speaking how do you with the law
how do you enforce that how do you know
and it creates all these problems but as
I say you can almost put that to the
side because the real issue is just it's
a person that's all from Patrick says a
big fan of yours Shapiro's and clave ins
I'm a 27 year old Republican staunchly
pro-life an NRA member with that said I
gave you a question of what is a woman
some thought and I think I came up with
an acceptable leftist definition I
talked about in the show yesterday how
leftist cannot define the word woman
it's a very simple preschool level
definition but they can't provide it
because their ideology won't let them
they use the word all the time they're
all into identity politics but they
can't say what a woman is and so I put
it out there I challenge that he left us
give me a definition of woman give me a
definition and so this is not a leftist
but he's gonna give it a shot he says
woman in an individual who is feminine
whose feminine qualities outweigh their
masculine qualities although I disagree
with this definition personally I think
this could fit into the leftist ideology
thank you for taking the time to read
this message look forward to your future
shows the problem there Patrick and I
know you gave it a college try you did
your best for the sake of the leftist I
know they probably appreciate that but
the problem Patrick is that the word
feminine is inextricably attached to the
word what more dependent upon the
definition of woman
so the definition of feminine is having
qualities or at appearance traditionally
associated with women especially
delicate delicacy and prettiness okay so
that's what feminine is having qualities
or an appearance traditionally
associated with women yeah well then you
need to know what woman is so you can't
give me a definition of woman that is
that just kind of taught to just punch
the ball back a little bit because then
you're still gonna get to this issue of
well what is woman they feminine is
qualities associated with women okay
what's a woman and that's that's the
issue so yeah that doesn't really do it
now this is from someone else who I
guess is a leftist and they really are
gonna take a crack at it try to define
woman it says you seem to be having
difficulty understanding the concept of
womanhood no I don't have difficulty
with it I'm saying that you do
that's my see if you're if you're a
liberal I I have no problem defining
woman a woman is an adult human female
that's a woman so I don't have any
problem with it I think that you do
unless I'm wrong so let's see what you
come up with a woman is an adult female
of course so that that makes the word
female the key term needing of
definition okay fair enough in that case
a female is an individual who identifies
with and likely possesses certain
qualities which characterize female hood
these being gentleness empathy
sensitivity caring sweetness compassion
tolerance nurturance deference and
succor ins although each of these traits
individually are not requirements it is
largely qualify as a matter of degree
and it's abundant presence as gender is
a status that exists along a spectrum
hopefully that clears things up no no it
does not clear things up at all not at
all so you you've actually you see I try
to be go easy on you I didn't make you
define female I was gonna make you do
that but you're going for female well
see the problem is female is a
biological term you've just tried to
redefine female to be not biological it
is a biological you may as well try to
redefine circle to be something other
than a shape is no that's not it
theme you know hi no beat females a
biological term and
a sociological sociological term or a
term that's dependent on a spectrum
because there are female cows there are
female turtles there are female fish and
birds and and and reptiles there are
females in in across the animal kingdom
they all have females too now you would
never say unless you're being unless
you're you know being not totally
serious you wouldn't talk about a woman
dog we may use that term colloquially
but no woman again that's a human female
though that and all the animals have
females so you're saying that a female
cow is gentleman is one that is gentle
empathetic sensitive caring that's what
a female dog that's how you define
female dog now you define a female dog
based on the reproductive capabilities
which is how you also define a female
person so that just doesn't that doesn't
work that's the wrong definition of
female you're just wrong
scientifically also this is not even a
definition what you're doing is you're
you're you're describing some of the
characteristics that oftentimes are
associated with the thing that needs to
be defined and I agree with you that
many times women are gentle empathetic
and sensitive but men can be that also
so you're telling me now that what if a
man is gentle apathetic insensitive he's
now a female not even just a woman
you're saying he's a female actually so
it's impossible then for there to be a
gentle empathetic and sensitive male so
apparently toxic masculinity is correct
I thought toxic masculinity was the
whole idea that a man can never be those
things that you listed and that's
supposed to be toxic that's wrong but
what you're saying is that no that's
right because if a guy acts that way
then he's actually a female and so hey
guys if you don't want to be a female
then you better not be gentle empathetic
sensitive or caring or compassionate
it's it's absurd if you were you can't
just you can't define something simply
by giving me a roundabout description of
some of the things associated with it
like if I were to ask you to define a
dog
you couldn't say oh well the definition
of dog is something that drinks out of
the toilet and chews up your couch now
it's true that a lot of dogs do that my
dog does that sadly but that doesn't
that's not what makes him a dog that's
not the definition of dog and there are
other things that drink out of toilets
and chew on couches there are other
animals that would probably behave that
way if you gave them the opportunity
there may even be people who would do
that does that make them dogs no that's
not a definition so here's the problem
your definition it's not a definition
it's scientifically wrong and it also
completely destroys all of the efforts
that I assume you align with to get rid
of the traditional definitions of
masculinity and femininity masculine and
feminine now those are words that do
exist on if you want to say somewhat of
a spectrum those are terms that that
that can be sort of that do change a
little bit with the time and with the
culture so for instance in some cultures
it's considered masculine for a man to
wear you know robe or a dress or a kilt
right as a clothing like that is
considered masculine in certain cultures
in our culture it's not so that is
culturally based masculine feminine and
in every person has some masculine
traits and some feminine traits some
people have more feminine than masculine
more masculine phone so that's true but
that's that's that is not the same as a
word like woman or a word like female
which are not culturally based which are
scientifically based and which are
dependent on our perceptions or our
impressions or our value systems it just
is what it is and those are also words
male female woman man that do not exist
on a spectrum there is no spectrum there
is woman there is man there is nothing
in between not doesn't exist there are
people with deformities mutations
sicknesses that caused them to have you
know a very small percentage of
malformed genitalia more ambiguous
genitalia but that that is not this that
does not make a spectrum and as I have
pointed out before there is not in
existence and never will be in existence
and over it never has been in existence
somebody who possesses the reproductive
capabilities of both genders and it
seems to me that in order to have a
spectrum you would need that missing
link you would need that right you go
for male male male female female female
on the spectrum well then right in
between there you would need someone
who's both just like on a color spectrum
you've got you know your primary color
your primary color and they blend into
the secondary color well then where are
the secondary colored people when it
comes to sex they don't exist
talking about someone with ambiguous
genitalia or malformed genitalia that is
not that is not both both would be
someone who has the the functioning
reproductive systems of both genders
that doesn't exist because it's it is it
is a is not a spectrum it is a binary
system so but thank you for the attempt
although you failed
alright well leave it there everybody
thanks for watching thanks for listening
Godspeed hey everyone I'm Alicia Krause
and we just wrapped a really great
episode of this month's conversation
with our very own Michael Knowles you
want to tell everybody some of the
things that we talked about I think we
might have had one or two questions
about abortion I think maybe that
because it's the biggest news story in
the whole kind of came up that came up
we talked about what it means for the
Supreme Court we talked about twenty
twenty Democrats we talked about faith
and Christianity and most importantly of
all we talked about cigars and whiskey
important topic much more important than
anything else so head on over daily
wire.com also available
all of our social media platforms
including the Michal Knowles page over
on iTunes that's right check it out